mariupl is being bombed into the past
ukrainians say economic infrastructure
factories warehouses are non-military
targets
survivors now suffering war
will inevitably suffer in the future
their livelihoods destroyed
on the ground russia's chechen soldiers
hardened fighters continue to push on
residential areas and suburbs waiting to
meet them may be ukrainian volunteers
like these men
actors singers artists
all defending their home
so far all people are volunteers who
basically never had a gun in their hands
never served in the army they never
thought that they would have a gun in
their hands
but all of them are with all of their
intentions determined to resist
and this desire just brought all of them
here
fear is natural he says to control it
you must embrace it
a small unit with little training
days away from going into the fray
to block russia's advance on the capital
mariopol kiev chernikev satellite
pictures show the russian army's use of
artillery where its ground forces have
been stalled by lethal ukrainian
hit-and-run attacks
another enemy jet was shot down
our forces have already shot down so
many russian jets and helicopters that
we can only state instead of containing
brains their pilots heads are empty i
said as well and this is not by accident
their hearts and souls are also empty
unharmed but not untouched by the
fighting
performers in drojobic have new roles
cooking meals for soldiers on the front
lines
there's a saying that when the gun sound
muses are silent but we are not silent
we are in the rear we are engaged in
volunteer work because ukraine is in a
difficult situation now
since the invasion began they've sent
thousands of meatballs and dumplings as
well as meat stew soup fish and pancakes
from here to kiev
as long as their people remain in harm's
way for this theater troupe the show
must go on zayn basravi al-jazeera lev
well let's get the latest uh from the
capital of kievan rankana standing by
there imran what is happening right now
well the curfew is about halfway through
this curfew was brought into effect uh
eight o'clock last night goes on until
eight uh sorry seven am wednesday
morning it's worth just taking a look at
the streets
kiev isn't
a busy city
anyway this city is about 50 percent uh
evacuated uh already the only people are
really left behind those people have
absolutely no choice and can't go
anywhere else the only things the only
people the only
cars we're seeing moving on the street
are actually things like that car over
there if you can see it uh with the
ukrainian flag on it it's actually
civilian car but inside our territorial
defense units they are volunteers who
are patrolling the city what could be
the reason for this curfew and why is it
lasting such a long time 35 hours well
there's a number of reasons the deputy
mayor suggests to do with shelling uh
others have suggested that it's actually
to do with the security operation to try
and look for russian saboteurs that may
be in the city it's not the first curfew
that we've been through in the last
couple of weeks there was one last week
lasted about the same time and that was
uh against i know that was an operation
trying to look for uh russian saboteurs
now uh that's the curfew but the
fighting is ongoing about 10 30 about an
hour and a half two hours ago now
actually
we heard
a very loud explosion near where we are
that was a cruise missile that was shot
down by ukrainian air defense systems
over the north of the city and this
seems to be a tactic that the russians
are employing more and more
the advance into kiev has actually
stalled
anecdotally i can tell you that that's
what ukrainians are telling us but it's
been backed up by the international
community particularly british defense
who are talking about the fact that the
russian army haven't managed to take air
take any major areas in the last a few
weeks and now we are going to see more
of these airstrikes we are going to see
more
of these artillery and shelling come
into the city uh whilst their soldiers
are still stalled on the outskirts but
the ukrainians are now mounting a
counter-offensive uh there's a suburb of
kiev it's suburbs a bit misleading uh as
a term it's actually in kiev old blast
just outside of the city it was an area
that had been uh taken by the russians
marquis here but uh the ukrainians have
managed to force them out
there's another area borisopol uh which
is near the international airport the
mayor there uh
is asking all of the citizens the
civilians there to evacuate the city to
allow the ukrainian army in to mount an
operation against russian forces that
might be on the outskirts and whilst all
that's going on ostomal butcher another
pin those three major front lines on the
edge of the city which if the russians
take allow them to use as a staging post
for any potential ground invasion into
the city fierce fighting is still going
on in those areas and indeed we've heard
air raid sirens and loss and explosions
from that area uh throughout the day
all right thanks for that imran khan
there in the capital let's
head west we go to lev now rob mcbride
is there for us and rob the president
zalensky saying he is ready to
compromise where are we exactly with
with talks and any negotiations
that's right there is this ongoing talk
about talks which theoretically is all
uh to the good we hear from the kremlin
for example that they have put forward
certain proposals to the ukrainian side
to which they have had some responses
but not responses to others without
going into any details about what those
proposals are we the
president zelensky's office is a little
more forthcoming so we have a better
idea of what any kind of negotiations
might look like for example uh this
major concession on giving up uh
application for joining uh of nato which
we know is uh one of uh which is one of
the reasons uh that uh russians are here
on ukrainian soil it is one of the major
issues with the russian side uh
president zielinski has already
intimated in the past that he'd be
willing to concede on that so that's
fairly easy for him to do also for
example to recognize russian as an
official language in parts of ukraine
that again is another
easy thing to concede from the ukrainian
side where the problem start of course
is on land and territory and whether you
concede land that as far as the
ukrainians are concerned has simply been
grabbed by uh russians as as part of
this uh as part of this exercise in
naked aggression do you reward that so
that's where the problems start but we
do hear from another advisor in
zilensky's office that they are
constantly in contact between the two
sides even if it is online there is a
lot of going back and forth but it is
around
various details such as the framework
for or a road map on going forward and
what the substantive issues are and so
when you get into this thicket of detail
it does make it sound as though any kind
of meeting between putin and zelensky is
still a long way off any kind of
peace deal uh still remains very far in
the distance or even just a ceasefire to
bring this fighting uh to an end so for
the moment at least obviously as we can
see around the country on so many
different fronts that fighting continues
all right rob thank you very much rob
mcbride there and live